hello everyone thanks for joining in I'm
super excited to be here at presenting
your private data Global feel free to
feel free to ask me any questions I want
to I want a session to be interactive at
this I have clip I have kept the slides
minimal I'll be going through
documentation how to get started with
training and how to check out like
evaluate different kind of accelerators
let's go so
this session I'm going to talk about
tpus gpus multiple accelerators
distributed strategies Etc
before starting with the session little
bit of introduction but myself I have
spent like good amount of time working
on open source so I should work as a
senior research engineer at lightning AI
it's a leading envelope company and I
was also a open source maintainer of a
framework called Pi touch Library
so this is the agenda of our session we
will give like an overview of Amazon
serrators like dpus ipus Habana then we
will discuss the fundamentals of
distributed training and then we will
discuss about the typical accelerator
how to like do distributed training on
that and get started with it and at the
end we'll I will have like a quick
summary of what we discussed and how you
can get started with it and we'll also
have like a five minute EMA click answer
your questions
awesome
overview of MLS servators so right now
there's a huge Innovation happening in
this space you will see like a lot of
funding news a lot of companies are
getting funded a lot of companies are
building accelerators languages like
optimized for like processing machine
learning workloads but before getting
into the ml accelerators part I want to
discuss a bit about the machine learning
life cycle
so machine learning lifecycle depends
heavily on data and the model right so
the quality of the quality of your model
depends very heavily on the quality of
data so it's very important to build a
paradigm around that so that's why
assert us the different kind of
accelerators like for example some asset
is do well with inference such and
ascertains do well with training and
such as let us optimize on like
different kind of much learning problems
like NLP or competition Etc
so this is how the different kind of
oscillators have worked on the first one
is a very common one the first one is
called CPU Center Processing Unit
everyone has worked on it and second one
which is like a game changer for the
Deep learning word it's called gpus
graphic Processing Unit so it's a very
common one was the most popular one
because it's supported by Nvidia and it
is based on Cuda so if you see a lot of
people training their huge models on
gpus and it's very easily accessible
right well it's available on AWS collab
Etc
and the third one is called Habana
Habana is something that was developed
by Intel so one good thing about abana
is like it's very cheap it's very
reasonable and you can get started with
it as soon as possible you can get
access to haban on AWS machines and you
can check out their tutorials on pytos
Latin dogs and even their own dogs as
well
and the fourth one is PPU which is which
will be the focus of the session if you
is tensor Processing Unit it's the hype
because it is supported by like multiple
AI Frameworks like tensorflow Fighters
Jacks and you will see a lot of academic
papers being published around that and
it also has like a lot of
companies also using it in their
production systems as well
and the fifth one is IPS so ipus was
built by a company called graphco it's
based out of UK and it was at one point
it was like one of the most funded ml
companies out there
and the last one but not the least the
MPS MPS is developed on Silicon M1
Chiefs which is available on your Mac
machines like a lot of people have their
MAC machines they can start training on
that and it's like there's a lot of
development going on towards a pie
touched side and it's been like a good
amount of development you can check that
out as well
so this is like an overview of how some
like a lot of new upcoming accelerators
as well like cerebral systems which
supports the training of huge models on
like a single chip and so this
faciliters
have like different kind of pros and
cons for example
one way to evaluate accelerators is like
checking out the ml puff benchmarks how
do they perform against multiple model
like different kind of models like NLP
models Transformers competition models
generative like stable diffusion models
Etc and the second we have to evaluate
uh estimators is like how is their
support with the framework right how
does it do well with python or
tensorflow Jacks that jazz does really
well with TPU so don't check that out as
well
so this is like an overview of about
different kind of machine learning
accelerators next we are going to cover
distributed training
so distribute training so you must know
like there's been a huge like a lot of
research and development in this space
in the last few years like we see a lot
of models like huge models with like
billions of parameters been trained and
a lot of academic research been
published almost every vehicle select
new kind of research out there on
Twitter social media Etc
so why are people getting into
distributed training and like why does
why is it necessary at this point
right so for I at this point I can think
of like main three point also if you
want to like increase the efficiency of
your training
you might start with CPU but it's like a
bottleneck you can't drain it on
multiple machines so you check out gpus
so if you want to like make your
training process faster you need to
shoot a training you need multiple
missions to train your models second if
you want to like fit in like large gate
up sizes of data in one machine you need
huge machines right for example
you have this data load a data set of
like thousands of samples data samples
but you want to like distribute it
across multiple machines you need
distributed break
and the third one is if you have a huge
model like if you have a model with
billions of parameters you can't fit it
on one machine that's when you need
that's what that's what you need like a
parallelization technique which will
stick the model into multiple machines
and you can do the forward pass or like
this like much like training the model
so these are like various reasons why
you need distributed training but
for example when I got started with
distribute training it was a bit
challenging because there was like a lot
of boilerplate we have to
select a lot of like moving Parts you
will take care of
uh need to create track first which is
like also repetitive code so there are
like multiple ways you can go wrong with
distributed training
so I will discuss in brief how you can
like not fall into that trap and get
started with it and also I will also
discuss in depth about different like
the core visual trading strategies
all right the the two main paradigms of
distributed training I'm going to
discuss is data parallelism and model
parallelism so what is data parallelism
right so I will show this small diagram
of different kind of
parallelism techniques the main one is
the the main Paradigm could you should
think of is like it might sound like
overwhelming again like a bit
uh confusing bust stay with me so data
parallelism is a strategy where the data
is split into end parts imagine you have
like a
imagine you have four gpus you have
access to four gpus which is great but
how do you split that how do you trade
models on that so one way you can look
at it is like you have this amount of
data like thousand one million data
samples so we can split the data into n
number of parts
and just think of this like W model you
have this net model then it will be the
same model on every GPU the data is
played and each GPU will see that part
of data for every Epoch for every
training process so that's how training
our data parallelism works so there are
multiple like they're like n number of
gpus the data is split into n number of
Parts is the same model on every GPU and
the weights get updated every time and
it's the same same model at the end of
the training process as well
got it just imagine there are five gpus
the data is the data has been formed
there's a forward pass that happens then
the gradients get calculated and the
gradients are collected and they're
averaged across multiple gpus and the
same gradients are sent to the backward
pass hence the weights are same across
the training process
and the second main one is called Model
parallelism so model parallelism happens
when you split the model when it's like
not possible to
fit the entire model of one machine so
it's like one bunch of data that's been
passed to the entire
all the machines like and this is how
it's processed just imagine like a
sequence of sequence of like multiple
parts of model that's how it works
so data parallel is a model parallelism
and they are much more like optimized a
distributed training strategies which
are going to cover next
[Applause]
all right so
before going to the multiple different
strategies like Optimal strategies for
like distributed training I'm going to
share this architecture overview we used
to follow at by touch lightning as you
can see at the left side of the diagram
there are Loops which is like the
training Loop validation Loop text to
prediction Loop this is just an overview
of like a for Loop for the Deep learning
workloads as you can see the strategy
box like the parity of handles
accelerator and we also have a Precision
cluster environment and checkpoint i o
the accelerator refers to the hardware
being used for the training or the
inference purposes
and we have this base clutch which
handles it and the second is the
Precision and what Precision you want to
lecture in your model what are the
inference work this helps to like reduce
the memory or like faster training or
inference processes and cluster
involvement which is the third one so
cluster environment takes care of your
cluster setup like how how's your GPU
set up Etc and fourth one is the
checkpoint i o checkpoint uh checkpoint
audio plugin it's called a plugin which
handles the saving and loading of
checkpoints also across multiple
machines how to handle that and forth
and also like how to delete checkpoints
so when you think of aspirators don't
just think of it as like just Hardware
it's an entire ecosystem it comes with
like that and I'll compilers also think
if it's like accessible through uh your
cloud services is it available on gcp is
it available AWS it depends on that as
well so like a lot of people also use
slums at like academic research Labs so
we also have support for that
all right next pie touch lightning so
I'm going to cover a bit about Pi torch
lighting how does it work and how it can
help you with your deep learning
projects so pytouch lighting it's a it's
a lightweight by touch framework which
helps you with scalability and
efficience it is like super charged with
multiple features I'm going to I will go
to a documentation to give a hint of how
it works
so this is the python lightning repo and
we can get started from here we have a
good readme and this is a design
philosophy we can check we try to help
you with flexibility for example if you
have like existing pie touch code how to
move to pipelch lightning but before
that I want to like introduce you to
like two main paradigms of fire touch
lighting the first one is called a
lightning module and the second one is
called a trainer so lighting model is
where you like Define your research code
this is where you like Define your
layers how to do the forward plus how to
do the training step
Etc
so I'm going to go go through like a
like a small minimal version of a
lightning model so you subclass the
lightning module and you define the
layers in the Constructor and there's
this forward
a method you have to Define so how the
forward pass should happen and there's
this training step for every training
step how should we like process the
batch and what and what kind of loss you
can return so that would be the loss and
this is something called a self log so
we also support like multiple kinds of
loggers like tensor but loggers words
and biases so you can just Define the
logger and you can just like you can
just uh Define the metric you want to
log as well like you are defining the
training loss right here MSC loss is
also the floss function so you can like
return the loss function and we have one
more method on configure optimizers
which like support multiple optimizers
and where you can like return the
optimizer you want to use so we have one
more method called configure schedulers
which is helpful like which you can also
integrate with your lightning model
so in brief lighting model is where you
defined your research code your pytouch
code so if you already have like a code
base of existing pytouch code this is
where you move the research code got it
and the second one is pytoslatic brainer
you must know like sometimes when you
work on deep learning projects there's a
lot of boiler period involved so our
moon our main philosophy with by touch
lightning is like we want to reduce the
boilerplate we want people to focus on
focus of research do not get into the
hassle of like handling the engineering
part so this is what the trainer does it
is supercharged with like multiple
features like Precision callbacks how to
handle the checkpointing Etc
so this is how the trainer works the
training part works first to like Define
a data set like a data loader then we
Define the lightning model which is the
models and third we Define the trainer
and then we call the dot fit dot fit
method only like the model the data
loader Etc
so in brief again I will cover this
again so this we have a lightning model
which defines a research code where you
can move your existing Pi torch code or
like write the pure research code and
Define the layers and the models and
second is the trainer where you can like
they are likely support like multiple
Flags which I'm going to look over now
all right let's go
so
I'm just going to show a different kind
of trainer Flags so what are the
different kind of trainer flights with
support as I mentioned in Python sliding
we Define we support like multiple kinds
of decorators so this is the
so the three main Flags to uh handle
distributed training or like training on
different centers is accelerator devices
and strategies
so just pass that set of flag to trainer
it could be either be CPU GPU TPU Auto
so we also have this flag called Auto
which Auto recognizes the Slater on your
system so the same script can run on
multiple machines and the second flag is
devices for example you have like five
five gpus so you can Define devices
equal to Phi and I said it was good GPU
right and it'll be like it will like
figure out the number of GPS available
on your machine and start training on
that see as you can see like you don't
have to handle the distributed training
logic you don't it's very hard it's very
easy to like get into the rabbit hole
and get distracted from the research and
like mess up your training process right
it's the same with TPU just defend as a
sppu and let it Define like one TPU
machine has a eight TPU cores and you
can get started training with that and
the third important strategy uh flag is
called strategy so we support different
kind of distributed training strategies
so it's DDP DDP spawn deep speed
colossal AI Etc so we can just pass the
flag to the trainer object and it will
handle Logic for you
flags for the trainer class
we do support multiple more uh Flags
like accumulating gradient batches like
for example when you are doing the
training it accumulates like every you
want the backup backward pass happening
the gradient accumulation happening
every every n number of batches like
gradient match is equal to six it will
happen after agree six every six batch
returns right
we support Auto scale we support Auto
Select gpus which if you don't know the
number of gpus present on your on your
machine it could Auto Select the gpus
available on your machine figure that
thing out
we will also we also have a flag which
will help you Auto detect the right
Learning grade for your training process
we also have this Benchmark which will
help you like find the bottlenecks in
your research code
and we have something called callbacks
where
we have defined multiple life cycle
methods hooks for your training process
for example you want to implement
something before the trainings training
training step Works after the training
step Works after uh a batch of the
training step is executed so we have
like multiple hooks where you can
Implement and like pass it to the
trainer object for example we have this
print callback which you want to say
like on train start and you want to
print that during the training process
on Trend and when the training is done
right you have to just pass the you have
to first Define the Callback and we'll
pass it to the callbacks flag to train
right and in machine it's very important
to check the performance you're training
on validation as well so if you want to
like check how is it working we have
this flag called check well every and
the box where
the training is working but after every
10 it talks 20 epox you have to check oh
how does it work how's your model
working validation data sets so we also
have that as well
we have discussed devices we have
discussed so
we also have this flag or enable
checkpointing there must be times you
don't want to save the checkpoints you
just want to check if it's working or
not so we can just it's a Boolean flag
where you can Define true or false one
second
beautiful
so you select these support more than 40
features you can check them out it's
very easy to use we handle a lot of in
general knowledge for you Etc
uh we also support different kind of uh
progress but we support the qdm reach
progress work
and we also supported a flag call number
of nodes for example you have cluster of
256 gpus which is available on different
kind of nodes right so you can pass a
number of noise is equal to eight so we
can handle cluster Logic for you too
right so this is trainer we discussed
trainer and here is the lightning model
so as if you have written pytorch code
before you would know like you have to
Define like a for Loop to
and like you have to like pass it to the
devices like dot Co dot dot to this
device you don't have to do it with byte
lightning model you don't have to Define
dot Coda dot to this device we handle
that logic for you so you have to just
write like Hardware agnostic code with
lighting model
right as we discussed you have to just
Define the forward method the training
step and you have to also Define like a
configure Optimizer to what Optimizer to
return
right in the in the documentation itself
you can see different kind of methods we
support
so this is like a basic
for Loop when you just use like vanilla
pie touch Loop first you have we first
will call a DOT train to put the model
in the train mode so it can enable the
gradient calculation then we have this
follow-up where we are iterating towards
multiple data set data samples of a data
loader then first call the training step
then we add it then we calculate the
loss then we like clear the gradients
then we do like a loss backward we'll
like find the to optimize to update the
parameters as well so you don't have to
write this logic we handle the logic in
a strategy classes
awesome so we have covered a bit about
python we have discussed the main two
paradiums lightning model which handles
the research core and trainer which
handles the engineering code for you
awesome what's next so the TPU
architecture so
I'm just going to give an overview of
what tipus is so tpus is something it's
tensor Processing Unit it's optimized
and it was developed it is optimized for
like
much learning workloads and it was
developed by the Google team it's
available on gcp it's available on
is such a hype a lot of business papers
are using tpus from Google meta Etc so
tpus used to have like a very strong
support from uh tensorflow but it's the
development has been very impressive
with pytorch as well so you can get
started with like pie torch on tpus too
and like the Google has this richest
research program where you can apply to
and get access to tpus so
this is just an architecture layout of
dpus and like as you can see
it has something called like a matrix
multiplication unit which is like 120
plus 128 there are multiple kind of
machines which is the V4 is The Descent
a recent uh recent a recent if you
architecture which was like uh launched
very recently and you can have access to
that as you can see these are the TPU
chips and like for every eight core type
YouTube there's like a TPU host you can
access to that if you host and get
access to that GPU chips
so this is how it works like you can go
to your gcp machine and we can spawn up
a machine and you can you can like
access to this via TPU host to your vs
code or like any other ID you like and
then you can start coding on that
so back to how to get started with like
pythonizing tpus we have this page
so if you go to the python slide into
occupations we have like different kind
of levels we have basic skills
intermitted skills Advanced skills and
expert skills So based on your level are
so expertise what you want to learn what
you want to experiment with you can
check out the skills and then there's
this we have this documentation for
every kind of accelerators like gpus
hpus IPOs tpus and also like the M1
chips right you can go to the previous
shapes your different kind of categories
like how to learn the basics of like
training on single gpus or like multiple
gpus how to scale like massive models or
using Cloud tpus there's an advanced on
like how to do debugging and this is FAQ
to troubleshoot selectable shooting your
models right
so but before getting into this I like I
want to like cover how why we need by
torch lighting for this right what if I
just want to use the vanilla pytouch
core to write code for like right like
to train models and tpus
so there's like a repo called python xli
which is which handles hand which
handles the PPU Logic for training by
touch models if you go to the
documentation
it's very similar to how you train on
gpus you you
so these packages torch xla is available
when you like go through the when you
assesses to the TPU machines it comes
with the predefined torch Excel packages
so this is where you're like defining a
tensor you have to like Define the
device it's trained on and you will get
a tensor which is available which is
like present on the debut devices
so you accelerate answers are pytos
tensors basically this is this is where
you can start working with tensors and
models
so how to one how to do like a simple
training on legs imagine this like a TPU
chip one TPU chip has like eight codes
so when you train on like one single PPU
core you don't need to do distributed
train but if you're training on like
eight GPU cores you need like some kind
of a strategy to train on it
this is The Simple Pie touch uh Pi touch
uh loop trading Loop to like train your
data we are like clearing the gradients
we are sending the data to the debut
device we are sending the model to the
dpu device and we are doing a backward
loss we are updating we're updating the
optimizer parameters as well so this XM
dot mark step is when like the all the
processes stop and that check if the
parameters are getting updated
so this is for like a single uh single
PPU device but we also they also have
support for like multiple TPU devices so
they use something called dot spawn so
this is how it works on like multiple
like eight cores
as you can see the code changes a bit
when you're training on like single TPU
device or like multiple review devices
so this is something called there's
something called pod TPU training as
well where you like train on a
collection of multiple TPU chips we do
have support for that as well with
python framework we were like one of the
first part like Frameworks to do that
like let's have that active support for
that so you can check check that out as
well
so as you can see there's a lot of
boilerplate it's the same core if you
like defining for multiple image
learning projects but with pythoning you
just have to mention I said it's going
to TPU you handle the hydrologic for you
as well
so I would just want to check the time
uh should I open the use should I open
the chat should I answer some questions
here
um yeah I was actually looking through
it I don't see uh any question being
posted at this moment
um yeah but I think we still have about
like uh three two three to four minutes
left
awesome yeah
okay uh so I'm going to also like uh go
to a dock how can how you can like start
with training on
like one trillion plus parameter models
and I'll go through that as well so
Titus has something called distributed
data parallel which handles the
which handles the training Logic for you
like it handles where you are very it's
like a wrapper Audio model which you
have to Define we support different
Advanced distributed strategies like
colossal AI which is doing great we also
support Fair skill which is by meta we
support uh started started techniques
which like it's optimized for like
cutting down the memory Etc
so do check it out do reach out to us
like reach out to me on Twitter social
media Etc if you have any questions
regarding that as you can see if you
want to like enable Fair scale you have
to just pass fhtp which is like a fair
scale implementation of data data
display strategy and you can also press
I'll Define the Precision you want to
use it's like 32 16 less than that yeah
do check it out
but it's very very
easy to get started with tpus and
like that there's been like good amount
of development happening it's bit stable
and you there's always like a python
pytos executive which will which is like
there to help you out